fallout 4 has had several DLC packs over
the past few months and we're getting
two more by the end of summer and
that'll be it I'm Tony and this is your
irradiated gamespot news update fallout
4 is vault-tec workshop is due this
month and nucca world is coming in
august that will be the final expansion
for the game as confirmed by Bethesda's
Pete Hines on Twitter nucca world is set
in an amusement park overrun by Raiders
with several different parks zones each
with their own quests and weapons and
secrets to discover if it's going to be
the final expansion for Fallout 4 at
least it sounds like a fun ride nuka
world will cost you 20 bucks by itself
but it also comes as part of Fallout 4
season pass as for what's next from
Bethesda fallout 4 director Todd Howard
has previously mentioned some quote big
and crazy projects that could mean
anything but if you want to stay
up-to-date on fallout Bethesda and
everything else from video game land
you're already in the right place
you